let's go next to Brian from Ireland
Brian welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hey David how are you okay yeah I'm
doing well yeah yeah I'm doing well
thanks very much
um
just a couple of small questions today
um
when Trump uh teased that announcement
and
you know it turned out to just be those
trading cards I I don't know I was I was
a bit you know it the whole thing has
been ridiculous for the last number of
years but yes I didn't think it would go
to this stage so that was a new low in
your mind the digital trading cards I I
I just I I don't know in in any of my
wildest dreams I didn't think that's
what the announcement was going to be
right I didn't know yeah but uh just one
like
what do you think here what what do you
think could be the next
um
bottom of the barrel that we find like
what could be the next just you know
just a wireless possible imagination
thing
um in the world of trump what honestly I
don't know is it is it Trump trump is it
Trump doing uh some kind of celebrity
boxing match I I honestly I have no clue
I have no idea because
every time there's a new low and we say
it can't possibly get any worse than
this then there's another new low is it
Trump doing infomercials for some kind
of uh rotisserie cooking device like Ron
popeil's you know uh whatever it was
called I I genuinely don't know Brian
you could tell me anything and I would
say it's possible that that will be the
next thing
yeah it's a
it's increasingly funny to imagine you
know if it got into a a Como back in I
don't know 2014 or whatever if someone's
waking up now just where do I start
explaining it would be completely
unbelievable no you're absolutely right
and and part of that I think is there's
an important lesson in there which is
even all of us in 2017 in January 2017
when Trump was inaugurated I think if we
had been told here's what it will be
like in 2022 most of us would not have
believed it
yeah 100 and now it is what it is you
know in Ireland are people just making
fun of trump like is he a laughing stock
um I it certainly he was for a long time
I think you know since
um
he left office and my guest left Twitter
Etc he's been
talks about a bit less but uh you know I
follow he has colleagues closer to most
people so I'm still interested but yeah
I think like most of my family wouldn't
know much these days but what he's up to
interesting it's probably for the best
to be honest
probably
um just one quick thing um on the World
Cup briefly why we can still talk about
that quickly but uh what um did you make
of the Argentina goalkeepers kind of
Mind Games in the penalty shootout do
you think that was a effective strategy
do you think that came into play or is
it being when you say mind games What
specifically are you referring to
well those I can't remember which of the
French
um takers it was whether it was their
the first one that missed or not but um
the the goalkeeper Martinez had the ball
in his hand and looked like he's going
to give it to the French clay but then
actually threw it away and made him walk
afterwards you know things like that oh
I didn't notice that that's interesting
I mean listen it was pretty funny my
view on all this stuff it's sort of like
this controversy about Chess Grand
Master and friend of the show Hikaru
Nakamura stalling in order to take
advantage of a rule related to how the
match clock relates to the game clock
it's sort of like if it's not against
the rules you figure out what to do to
win and I don't know if throwing the
ball I I just I don't have much of a
feeling on it one way or the other you
know
yeah not fair enough yeah no I I I'm not
certainly not accusing them breaking
rules or anything I just thought it was
interesting uh that he was getting into
the French player's head and the team to
work to a degree so Hey listen real
quick a friend of mine when he was in
Ireland went on a potato walking food
tour where it sounds like a joke but he
would stop at they would stop at
different places with a local guide each
Place preparing potatoes in dramatically
different ways is is that a complete
tourist trap or is that actually
something like locally interesting
culinarily in in Ireland
well I haven't heard of that specific
attraction but to be honest to be
perfectly honest with you even though it
is a stereotype I I would still uh go on
that tour let those sound I love
potatoes I mean it sounds pretty good to
me yeah I have to say if you're if
you're at a wedding here in Ireland I'll
finish up with this but if you're a
guest at a wedding
um and it's kind of food being served
family style you know dishes Etc yeah
there'll be there'll be three different
types of potato at least you know
they're being mashed they're being um
dolphin oils whatever you know there's
going to be a few different options I
like that that's it all right well I
gotta get over there and try some of
these potatoes I have to tell you
please do all right good to talk to you
later all right Brian from Ireland thank
you so much for the call very much
appreciate it let's go to Jill from
Burbank California Jill welcome to the
program what is on your mind today
hey David how you doing I'm doing well
okay uh well big fan and uh just have
many questions I have written them down
but I'm just gonna do two of them
um I don't know whenever we watch one of
those Trump trump rallies at the end he
says this country doesn't belong to them
this country belongs to you yes isn't
that a fascist like that's the biggest
dagger in like America's throat saying
this country basically belongs to you
guys only what America is is all about
uh you know everybody else and we love
our neighbors like well if you if you
question them about it they would say
what Trump means is this is the country
of the people not not literally just the
people at the Trump rally it's just the
country of the people is what they say
is meant by it
well to me how it sounds it's those
people and not the other people totally
fair I'm just telling you like if you
confronted them with it this is what
they would say
I I mean they they say a lot of a lot of
things that like that are HIPAA uh
basically that made them uh Hypocrites
yes like the one I saw from yesterday
the lady was driving a uh SUV with an uh
hashtag fjb in the back yep but she had
like all the Christmas stuff
around it Christmas stands for like love
you know and everything like from uh you
know sharing and caring and all like
that's what Christmas is and she but I
mean how can she be Evangelical or a
Christian true Christian and
also put in you know FJ being in the
back of the car that really blew my mind
I'm with you that hypocrisy is is quite
stunning but it is prevalent and it is
uh it's like its own virus in the United
States
right uh can I can I do one more
question this this is going to be
actually a question all right
those were just statements it's better
when people just get right to questions
going forward but I'll I'll allow it's
got to be real quick though I got a lot
of people holding
okay uh so if you remember Trump said
oranges of the investigation and he said
it like many many times and then he
explained it as origin like uh the
beginning
Beginnings so that was
from many many many many many uh
examples the other one was during the
rally he said oh Mark Zuckerberg last
week came to the White House and he was
out of the you know yeah it was like
years after he left the Oval Office yeah
right so is he done did in your in your
uh in your head is is he done done uh
from a mental standpoint listen I don't
know I don't know because on the one
hand Trump does remember things and can
sometimes be coherent but he just like
glitches so much and I I I I really
don't know what's going on with Trump
cognitively I'm not sure I'm not really
in a position to say it's very strange
and that's what our position has been as
bizarre and as he just loses his train
of thought and that type of thing but
ultimately I don't know what's going on
question probably more for a neurologist
right okay maybe we should have a
neurologist on on your show up to go
over Jill I will look into it I
appreciate the call thank you all right
thank you all right let's uh a lot going
on there a lot lot going on there let's
go uh actually you know what let's let's
take a very quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because we're
going back to the phones but we're going
to take a very brief break reset let
emotions simmer and then we'll hear from
some more people in a moment